no they're not regular white people no
they're not they're not they're hard
people yeah yeah no but you see that in
the UFC there's a lot of badass rush
well obviously we now we saw that
recently enough yeah when on topic honor
punched him in the face saying let's
talk now yeah look yeah talk boom let's
talk come on we talked bone just
twisting errific yeah yeah yeah and then
they got those other videos that you see
on YouTube and whatnot of Russians just
up in in steel i-beams yeah like a
hundred stories up backflip swinging to
backflips hanging by two fingers
isn't that rolling and sometimes falling
yeah my hands are sweating are you just
talking about that makes my hands you
know it is so uncomfortable to watch
oh and because they're they get
themselves in these positions where
maybe there's this thin little alcove
yeah and and they put their hands
against one side their feet against the
other this if your feet slip there's no
no recovering drives me crazy reaction
to just the thought and I have some
friends that just know that I freaked
actually send me those everyone Christ
yeah there are some things that are
online oh my god oh they are nuts I
can't do this man oh look my hands are
pouring so yeah yeah oh my god look at
this crazy [ __ ] always I film you
crazy [ __ ] what does it say daredevil
returns with latest shocking stunts on
skyscraper this [ __ ] [ __ ] but
he's doing a handstand on what is that a
three-inch ledge oh my god oh he's going
around the come on come on
what are you doing [ __ ] do it one little
one little [ __ ] miscalculation or how
do you do that
how do you know your center of gravity
isn't just gonna pull your right - [ __ ]
off
Jesus Christ he went around the corner
that's nuts what is this guy's life like
if he does decides he's gonna do this
this makes me very uncomfortable that is
so [ __ ] high of it's so that is so
high of I wouldn't I can't do what he
did it is on the ground right yeah yeah
I can't I can't do those handstands and
all that jazz right now mark out three
inches and try to stay on it with your
hand or mark it up enough so that you
like put pads under me right right and
then give it so I could jump up and grab
it and hang yeah yeah see how much that
I could do like a couple things I could
gain from my fingers I might be able to
pull myself up but if I got to the top I
probably slip yeah yeah you know a
height will definitely [ __ ] with you
like if you're riding a bike on a
sidewalk you'll never fall off the
sidewalk right you could just ride your
bike you don't even have to think about
it sidewalk what couple of feet wide if
that was over like the Grand Canyon you
you would you would be shaking you
couldn't do it and it's the same [ __ ]
thing it's just your your perception and
the height and you know you'd be [ __ ]
up you'd be like this I'm gonna fall off
whee